[Music]
off the record here we go
oh we're doing off the record
oh my god they're flirting as usual
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we
mexico was dope it was super dope first
time on a plane
in the last year because i'm gonna trip
you out it did trip me and i mean i was
cool
except for the dude sitting next to me
that i didn't know
about rubbing shoulders and [ __ ] i was
like oh you know what's weird you before
you
get on the plane right yeah six feet sit
everyone
in line six feet and then when you're
all up on the plane
excuse me excuse me i'm not 100 sure how
it goes down
does that make sense to you you're not
restaurants now there's like just
covered up here
yeah but then when you bam boom no
it disappears that's why we're sitting
down because there's no covet down
exactly you think about this i mean at
the end of the day it's all
social norms now yep which is cool
yeah it's kind of like a remnants of the
past
that's going to change well i feel like
we're out of the woods right now the
thing that's crazy to me with that whole
situation so
the anti-vaxxers right that when you
wear a mask say you go to place
and antibacterial ain't wearing a mask
and they're like looking at you because
they're like
i am anti-vaxxer and you're a punk ass
wearing a mask
so now that the masks are off and we're
on the honor system basically they're
saying
if you had the vaccine take your mask
off but if you
are an anti-vaxxer you gotta wear a mask
so now the guys got now the anti-factor
to prove that they're anti-vaxxers oh
that's good they have to wear a mask
so now that the place is going y'all
[ __ ] are whack
i'm wearing a mask because i don't
believe in this [ __ ] where the [ __ ] are
you wait they won't though they won't i
know
they won't be hypocrites they won't be a
hypocrite they won't be hypocrites
they want you want the ones that stand
strong they're gonna walk into that
place with a mask on
like six years from now like oh i just
still got don't got no facts well that's
the thing too the people that got
vaccines
you know like they're still wearing
masks too you know there's a number of
people that are still wearing i saw a
news article about that it's all over
this place like whether you wear want to
wear a mask don't wear a mask
vaccine no vaccine i went to hawaii
right and even if you have the vaccine
you still have to take the test you
still have to wear the mask
in kabul we have to take the test field
got back on the plane they came to our
house and they hit us up my thing is she
was like i just want to get home i don't
care like whatever we got to do to get
i'm not staying in mexico for like two
weeks what's it like being a different
country experiencing
like pandemic i guess the tail end of
pandemic now but like i haven't
had not left this country since i've
been on a plane in years i know
like but being in mexico like was it
different there everyone was wearing a
mask
really yeah wow and except you know at
the restaurant you take the mask off
same rules same rules same rules
standardized crosstalk
it's so weird traveling and then like
seeing how
all of us are kind of in the same thing
together
yeah like it just this thing connected
everyone it's a con you know it's a
shared
human event but it's also weird to see
everyone has a different perspective on
it
so like you know biden he just said like
pretty much
if you're vaccinated you don't have to
wear a mask or whatever and
if we're gonna take it off soon like
it's like a positive statement yeah
and then i go in the comments and
there's comments i go
too soon buddy i'm keeping mine on i'm
like
wait what the [ __ ] like there's like
whether it's science
gets laid out people have their opinions
and no one's following it and then now
we have laws that are being laid out and
then everyone has their own take on it
and then it's just like
well and there's the people who go 1776
you don't have a right to tell me and
they're like this is the guideline
i know we know that just a
[Laughter]
there's like social norms that happen
that just forever will change you know
what i'm saying like
like after 9 11 all the tsa stuff
happened yeah and so now we all be going
plants
you ain't going on a plane for the rest
of your life without going through a
heavy tsa situation
when everyone knows if we really sit and
think about it and tsa knows too
it's a 0.001 percent chance to end
this shit's happening not only that when
you sit there and you're like
in the tsa line and you're waiting and
you're seeing them shake down some
housewife from montana and her [ __ ]
shampoo you're like that ain't no
[ __ ] bomb dude
yeah that ain't no [ __ ] bomb and if
you got if the real dudes were coming
through here
y'all here at this tsa booth
are not ready for it a and b you guys
are
thinking that the terrorists are some
regular joe schmoes from other countries
it's [ __ ] james bond cias of other
countries
you think they're getting stopped at the
[ __ ] tsa
or what are we [ __ ] talking about
this [ __ ] when you walk through this
what are we doing they know it doesn't
work they know what they want
when you arrive at your destination and
you go in your hotel room and you open
your backpack and you're like
how did this knife get through dude
i didn't even know i had a knife in my
backpack the whole time
and i went through this i was in vietnam
and i had a big
joint in a tube in my backpack and i was
like oh my god i could have [ __ ]
totally been in jail right now
you're like does this work or not it
worked for me
because i was in i was rushing and i
just packed real quick so i had to go to
australia
and then like i went through tsa and
then they're like is this your bag and
i'm like yeah
[ __ ] randomly stopped again dude and i'm
just waiting and i'm like hurry the [ __ ]
up i gotta catch my flight right they're
like
sir you have a clip a fully loaded clip
and i'm like what are you talking about
and then they pulled out my [ __ ]
magazine with bullets in it and i'm like
yeah i went shooting the other day and i
used that bag and i didn't take all the
bullets out and everything and i'm like
did you throw it away
i'll they're they they were gonna stand
they're gonna let me keep they're just
like you want to put it on your carry-on
and i'm like i'm gonna be late just keep
it
you should be like you're blowing my
cover mother
oh i'm so sorry i'm just right here but
there's this lady in front of me right
and
she was just watching the whole [ __ ] go
down and her face was like
she saw a dead person and then she just
saw that they let me go
and i was mad at them and i'm like
that's mine and i'm like [ __ ] and i
in my heart i'm like oh [ __ ] i hope i
don't go to jail after that you get on
the plane you take your clip
just throw one bullet
what the [ __ ] does she think you're
gonna do with it there was no gun
thankfully
if i had a gun and that dude different
story yeah
my buddy richard he does um shooting
videos on youtube
and he has taken like a whole like
armory
through the airport what and he just but
you check it in though
oh he does it the legal way he's here
yeah but he also has he said well yeah
but he also has a federal manufacturer's
license oh yeah
he's got a friend yeah he's legit he's
like he's a legit
car character you do it all the time you
know like you go on hunting trips or
whatever you take your guns but there's
a way to do it legally you can't have it
loaded in your backpack on your carry-on
can't have it in the cabin
i don't have a gun yeah why i don't know
i have no need for guys
i have a samurai sword okay nice are you
sick i do too actually
i have a samurai sword if someone come
in my crib
i'm gonna chop that [ __ ] up one
time well you just told them how how you
will
how they could defeat you i know i know
what you do you're gonna train for it
yeah but then if they have a gun
i'm pretty sure you're not gonna be able
to win with this are you fast with this
oh you might be able to like if they
shoot
[ __ ] [ __ ] you can cut the
bullets in half can you slice the
airsoft bullet
i think [ __ ] i mean i'm my hopes would
be i would be like hiding behind one of
the like i hear some [ __ ]
and i get it would hide behind like in a
closet so i can it's got to be a
surprise situation oh yeah
is it a real samurai sword you got it
from brook stones no it's a real
the dull one yeah do they shout display
what about the gold sword you got the
gold sword i do got the gold but it's
not sharp
oh but i could poke somebody with it i
could poke somebody with that one
you might be able to do some damage with
it i don't have you ever
have we all had swords yeah have you
ever hit anybody
yup do you want
i had a chinese broadsword from kung fu
when i was a kid
those wiggly swords don't do [ __ ] no
it's a traditional sword original one
yeah
and i was trying to chop the tree down
in front of my mom's house
and i [ __ ] broke that sword in half
what yeah
i was just whacking it like a [ __ ]
baseball bat and it [ __ ] broke
out today's video is brought to you by
hbo max and i gotta give a really
awesome thank you to hbo max because
when me and bart first started
doing anything in the digital space or
entertainment
there was no love for the asian
community there wasn't much
content being created for it it was
really hard and there was no
distribution
but now we have massive channels like
hbo having
tons of content like american produced
as well as
asian produced content all being on hbo
max where you could watch
like various shows like warrior or like
movies from studio ghibli
and it's pretty dang amazing yeah and
it's uh what i love about it the most
is so you know when you when you're when
you're going to being american it's
really hard to find asian american
stories but now we can't but also more
importantly it's being
distributed and shown to the masses so
it bridges the gap that way
you know growing up i liked italian
films now italians can also watch our
stuff
so it's just that's what i think true
america is all about so if you want to
watch stories and narratives told by
asian americans go check it out it is
aapi month like joe said there's all
kinds of shows over there so go on the
link below
click go to hbo max now and you can
start streaming all these wonderful
shows
check it out but i am we talked about
this before but i you know
there i was at a comic con and there was
these guys doing a samurai sword
exhibition and i was like all right and
then i just talked to him in the green
room afterwards and i was like
hey yo so i got a samurai sword hey yo
do you guys get any [ __ ]
they were like actually that's what i
heard when this guy said this is a
cutlass
and i asked i asked my dude what i
should do if the guy comes to my house
like do i
like jab at him or should i like try to
like break his arm like a baseball like
and the guy looked at me and he's like a
southern dude from like louisiana doing
the whole
samurai sword exhibition is he white he
was white
and he was like you have a semi sore son
excuse me sir it's samurai i said what
does it what do you mean he goes
do you know what the samurai do i go
what do they do you guys
they slice through the body i said what
he goes you slice through the body and
he's like oh
you know what you know what samurai do
they [ __ ] [ __ ] up
and so my guy's like telling me no
you're not trying to break [ __ ] or
nothing you're
slicing through the body they even
followed the bushido
exactly have you read the seven rings he
showed me some video where they hung
these seven
like dogs up the special doctor their
bodies are like human and the
samurai guy sliced through sev the
pelvis one slice yeah yeah
like those swords are insane and i'm
like what he got so
so i'm saying the guy so i'm talking a
guy like my dude
the guy comes to my house he's trying to
steal a [ __ ] laptop or something
and i hide behind the corner and then i
and i slice through his [ __ ] body
yeah you know and then he's like
it's a tory han show
he's like just trying to steal a [ __ ]
ipad and he just locked
[ __ ] half his body if you know how to
use it though
that's [ __ ] up but it's shaped like
this to
to go like this it's shaped to arch you
need to
could you imagine if you sliced through
someone's whole [ __ ] body
you would you would be so traumatized by
that [ __ ] like i got that dude
and you gotta move in your house imagine
just walking to the bathroom you're like
oh that's right oh
if someone tried to kill me i wouldn't
feel bad at all hey but if you
what if you were just trying to take
your ipad
how do i tell the difference i don't
know but like he tells you when he's on
the floor he's just like
are you trying to kill me or take my
okay just go ahead just take it get the
[ __ ] out of here
i saw you had an expensive guitar and i
thought maybe i could grab it
i think you could meet in the middle
right if he says i'm trying to take your
ipad
then you cut off his arm and if he says
if i try to kill you then you got to
slice them in half
yeah i think that's the meat in the
middle you think you could slice someone
in half of yours you see
yeah easy yeah he for sure could
you see this guy's arms bro i don't want
his strength or speed
it's not about his arms it's about his
determination that's what scares me the
most i'll try
and then i'll get stuck at the spine
i feel like it's like one of those magic
things like a real like kung fu movie
[ __ ] where it's like you have to believe
you can slice through
the whole body yeah that's true i feel
like for me it'll go up
and just get stuck there or it's like
punching a hole through the piece of
paper and it's like that's the final
test you gotta punch through it
you can't punch through it then how are
you gonna cut somebody in half with a
samurai sword
[ __ ] outta here you could punch through
a piece of paper that's that was like
the old
that's all the kung fu movies like
that's my test yeah yeah now they do
bricks all kinds of [ __ ] exactly paper
was back yeah
yeah gravity was stronger everything was
wrong but goal pulse that moved you know
wait so you don't have a gun
i don't got a gun how come you don't
have a gun don't advertise that what if
someone targets him
i know i mean if i live if i lived in a
country i would get a gun but like i
live
like in like beverly hills i'm cool
if someone comes and wants some [ __ ] i'd
be like take it
you probably need it more than i do if
you're here for it and you're doing some
[ __ ] beverly hills police as i heard is
pretty good
yeah they're looking pretty good they're
very very good didn't that guy there's a
guy who's like at a coffee shop with the
richard mille on and then
someone just took it at gunpoint right
and it just blasted his girl
yeah oh yeah i did i i didn't i did hear
about that i did hear about that
was it the blue one i don't know one of
those expensive ass ones what are you
doing
my [ __ ] hip hurts man would you give
your rolling up would you give your
rolly up what do you got on
it's not worth my life okay yeah wait
wait how much
if you had a gun i'll give up my rolly
but my g-shock
i'ma [ __ ] die for this dude what if
my dude didn't have a gun he was just
like
i want that watch i'll be like kiss me
for it then fo
yeah and see what he does joe's gonna do
is i wouldn't want to get a fight with
because he just would just i was at the
taco bell
right i would have to taco bell down the
street this was in college
and then he was i was like oh and then i
had my had my hat on
and he's like hey fool give me your hat
and i'm like this one
and then i [ __ ] chucked it as far as
i could
and i was like go get it he goes no you
go get it and i'm like go get it it's
over there
get it
[Laughter]
joe's like a [ __ ] loose cannon you're
like you don't know what he's going to
do he's a wild card
my cousin was like that we were in the
hoodies like compton some guys hit him
up some gangsters like and i was like
where
are you from full like i said where you
from and he's like
i'm from the moon that's all you got to
do they were like wake up frill though
and they were just like take me i'm
serious they're at mcdonald's and they
were just like
you're [ __ ] crazy like trying to like
check you but now we realize
you ain't even playing on the same field
as us with joe you just never know
because they could be like
hey let me see that right here dude sure
do you like it kiss me for it
i think that's like the most like uh you
how you could de-escalate a situation
we're like you want to fight i'm like
nah but i wanna kiss
yeah that always scares people off for
sure remember that one
stupid prankster that would go around
and then he would be like hey fool you
wanna fight and they're like what and
then he pulls his pants down and then
and then he's like a g string of [ __ ]
and they run
those pranksters got just clocked in the
face you know those guys
pranking people in the streets on
youtube and stuff i've seen a lot of
them get cold
get knocked out cold there was one where
a guy for sure
i saw one where a guy was tying his
shoes and he goes up to the guy
as he's bent over and he has a fart
sound effect and he grabs his head
presses the far sound effect and the guy
beat his [ __ ] ass as he deserves
oh [ __ ] you touched him you can't say
bro what are you doing play stupid games
win stupid prizes
he's like it's a prank it's a prank but
i'm just getting [ __ ] up have you seen
this where there were like these guys
were about to fight it was like an asian
guy
and um like this short little dude
they're pushing each other back and
forth
he takes his shirt off right and then he
takes his pants off
and he has his dick hanging out and he
starts
getting into a fighting position naked
no one knows and the other guy runs away
it's a scare tactic but everyone was
laughing at him was going to jerk off on
him maybe
but if you get ready for the fight they
can fight you just get naked like
what's going on nobody wants to fight a
guy that's naked bro
nobody want to find a naked dude bro
nobody wants to do that i think the
hierarchy it goes like
you want to fight and then this person's
like oh you mean have sex
and you're like oh [ __ ] but then i think
the guy goes i want to eat you
then it goes oh [ __ ] that guy is really
crazy the cannibalism huh you know what
i
mean
oh
a gentleman's fight yeah we're like i'm
viewing him as a gentleman he's real and
then but then if he looks at me
like i'm a pocket [ __ ] then i'm like oh
[ __ ] we're not even
like i'm prey to him yeah but then if
another guy's looking at him
like he's a meal like he's a [ __ ]
tri-tip or some [ __ ] then it's like oh
this guy's
this guy's really crazy one wants to
kiss me one wants to bite me
the highest level is that the highest
and the other guy's maybe i want to wear
his
i want to wear his skin yeah the skin
yeah the other guy's like i'm gonna scan
him and wear him
yeah that's the crazy thing ah that
people are nuts i don't want to deal
with any of that [ __ ]
no this is the guy to kiss people
i'm using psychological warfare
i don't really mean it i'm just trying
to like we're going off your scale bro
you've already out crazied all of us in
this room
i'm just trying to defuse the situation
you're just trying to kiss not make love
yeah oh okay actually no strings
attached guys come on oh okay okay
because what are you going to say to a
guy that says oh you want to fight and
says oh you want to kiss me what are you
going to do
kiss him yeah if you're ballsy enough if
if you're dante you'd [ __ ] be like
all right i'm i'm about to let's do it
i've done a few movies
i'm let's go actor bro i haven't been
challenged in a long time oh you know
what it reminds me of
um when you when you did your poem about
pick your nose oh yeah yeah you know
you disarm him a little bit yeah at
least at least he gets him out of it
yeah unless that disarming triggers them
steve's really good with that because he
used to do the [ __ ]
pranks and he did pranks guys would be
tough with him what did you do did you
get socked ever
you just try to scare them with how
crazy you could be back or but
i'm pretty good at doing like um uh i
can pretty much tell like what their
tail is usually
like what their button is and i i'm like
it's usually like they don't want to be
seen as gay or whatever
that's a big one it's a big one for a
lot of those guys who are going to the
more macho they are the more yeah
you like you play stupid too gay [ __ ]
they do that i don't play no gay [ __ ]
and they run away but i think the
difference is you give people
an opportunity to kind of go out yeah i
give them
i give them an opportunity to to rectify
the situation because for example
i used to do this one where i would go
up to guys while they're walking hand in
hand with their girls and i'm like
and i would start hitting on the girl
immediately i'm like hey what's going on
with you like are you hanging with your
brother
you hate college and i would never
an interracial couple i would never
crack even a smile or blink weirdly or
anything
and we had hidden cameras everywhere so
you couldn't tell you're too good man
that's hilarious and that was the
that's the whole thing it's not funny if
i'm like as it's happening i'm like
no like what's going on with you like
what's the deal like let me get your
number like and the guy's [ __ ] fuming
yeah and then i'm like oh dude this one
nice to meet you like obviously like
it's cool to me family or whatever
like you just if you do that but then
there's one guy he started stepping
pretty hard
he like grabs my cell phone from me and
i'm like um and i'm like
hey dude like that's my phone hey your
brother's kind of messed up dude
can you tell your brother to grab and
give my phone back hey dude can you put
my number in there like
hey can you put her number in there like
do you know it like what's going on
if you just keep going you don't give up
then they're just like what the [ __ ] is
with this guy
and they don't necessarily want to fight
you but if they do get to the point
where they want to fight you
you can disarm them pretty easily i had
one guy um he was definitely about to
about to fight me and he was like he was
like do you want to go right now and i
was like where do you want to go dude
let's go there
and then he's just like what the [ __ ]
you're talking about like [ __ ] like that
where you just like
you gotta go if they ask you if you want
to fight that means
there's still hope you can still salvage
them that's true because people that are
violent will start swinging at yeah
yeah yeah if they ask you like you want
to fight or something you want to step
this outside or some [ __ ] that's when
you're like all right i still got you
when people
prepare you to fight they know it's
either they're preparing themselves
they're yeah or or they're they're they
just want to bully intimidate and
hopefully
look good while you cower when someone
hits you right in the face
you're done it's ready that's it lights
out yeah yeah when they just load up
you're like oh [ __ ]
oh this dude's really about it they're
not playing that [ __ ]
[Music]
you